[Music]
[Applause]
league in soup invoicing de for spatial
and anger and what many things de Lage
mini for effort en de conflict
macho banks is director at those who dc
expanse over column in hostilities
there is our line that the international
community cornerstone series chain
motionless khalifa ft
eco always the the internationally
recognized comment
the lot entrance point 2 weeks ago with
people eateries and info sessions fire
even standing naida the international
community and europe in particular
is als divided en saba en retains
the same problem
help is i have  many here on year
nature night at the fighting and in libya
french needling
england' t train dead by third parties
did and for senate thomas
well we some is out of your name
maybe the really possible original
idea what he did  om police good hope
zo
the united states want zo folon libya
issues that remained largely silent bio
and android libya cheese and salami
als bab  y swing both sides to try and
pants and leggings is where the
safehouse well good luck
the have a modem won hundred by lion's
city commit and john your de 12 3 suppose
to be and arms in balk oh we have 2
stages and columns between coastline and two and a
half  thousand columns online
bodewes x countries and for sing is
down in possible and or concerns about
sites like styling weapons and equipment
and cavell with foils and paper i a
ghost there is a foil samsung fighting
the bank and family carbon united arab
emirates
if you a mole  en 3000 our weapons
including grants to hate as forces and
tutor choose create flight' this we live
off the coast of libya the a2 adhesive foil
2000 so and produce in fighters
by set baby and forcing chip blew the
fans is well turkey 9 palace dorky game
of death was invented
in do of the at the chin micro sd
have net straps
religion government so they would like to
now they ali b yes coming
that a half lights that i know
smuggling becomes that we that what he
died for someone's and hip just marley
bob are
department chairman within talking
chiplead weakness and that series of evert
and man
diabolical impulses blog he that leopold
and so far' cost country nelie seven
hundred million dollars economists are
packing already be  seen
rubbish styling in the comics the haircut
the cursor is still in 8 minutes passwords
and prices of starting to rise
the hood with is dedicated so tangible not
international help
this season is that oil water is
conflict and with cool die the cb preseli
dat and the  solution moby than to keep
quite a lot of
tony berkley 7 club oil